oh you know I I think my's absolutely
right I think we're overloaded on
attention and I think that in 10 20
years we're going to go crazy you see
emper Rose going crazy you see Britney
rener going a bit nuts and you see us
you know taking our clothes off more and
more and more and more to get the
attention that we're never going to get
back I'm sorry there's nothing you can
do to get the attention you had at 18
there's nothing you can do to get the
attention that you had at 21 it's gone
NADA and and you can't get it back and
the problem is we just keep selling
women this dream of you're youthful
forever you're young forever you're
going to have the same options in 10
years as you do now and they're lying
and that's why I really just that's why
I go so hard on the tradcons because
they're supposed to be the ones that are
telling us the truth